we're going to begin this hour with the
sentencing of former socialite gallane
maxwell who was sentenced to prison for
20 years yesterday for helping jeffrey
epstein sexually abuse underage girls
now maxwell was convicted of five
charges including child sex trafficking
recruiting and grooming underage girls
between 1994 and 2004
any farmer we're happy to say is one of
the survivors who testified at the trial
she says she was just 16 when she met
epstein and maxwell and was groped by
both of them
farmer testified that maxwell's presence
made her think that she'd be safe around
epstein and annie farmer joins us in
studio annie i'm so glad to see you in
person really glad you're here i was
thinking about you yesterday tell us
what the day was like for you how you
felt
it was a very intense day emotionally
but
it was also a tremendous relief to hear
that sentence read and to know that
she's going to be spending the majority
of her life behind bars for the crime
she's committed and before she was
sentenced you read a victim impact
statement yeah i'm not asking you to
read it verbatim but what was your
message
uh i really spoke directly to the judge
i wanted
her to take into account some of the
long-term impacts that these kinds of
crimes have and have had for me and for
my sister maria and i wanted her to
understand that there's systemic effects
of those that it's not just about those
individuals but also about all their
loved ones and the pain and suffering
that you know communities go through
because of these crimes um and then for
me also the lack of remorse that she'd
shown and how this fight for justice
because she would not be honest because
she continued to lie how much that
created a black hole for all of us of
having to continue to fight put our time
and energy in to
you know making this day happen yeah it
was the black hole line that got me
yesterday annie when you said that you
know and she did uh gallane maxwell did
get up and speak did it surprise you
that she spoke it did
i don't think any of us were really
expecting that
but was it satisfying to you did it give
you
some form of justice to hear did you did
you accept her apology did you think it
was an apology i didn't think it was an
analogy she didn't take you know any
responsibility she acknowledged that
there was pain and suffering but she did
not take ownership of causing that pain
and suffering so it felt very hollow to
me and the other women i spoke with
afterwards did you ever make eye contact
with her were you trying to make eye
contact with her is a better question i
i actually did make an attempt uh
several times during my impact statement
to make eye contact with her and look
directly at where she was sitting and
she she just looked down she never
looked back
she says her lawyer says that she's
going to appeal the sentence
i'm not surprised to hear that but i
don't expect that she'll have much luck
with that i think that
you know it was a clear case i think the
judge was very fair in her rulings and i
don't expect she'll be getting out of
prison for a long time
and that makes you
very relieved yeah
did you feel a sense of closure
i think closure is a tricky word yeah i
do too i do too yeah so there's you know
it's all still sinking in
um i think for a lot of us that have
been involved in this we will
you know our heart is with these issues
and we'll be continuing to work towards
helping other people that have had these
experiences but i hope that this is
closure for this case
you know it says maxwell was convicted
of grooming underage girls and i think a
lot of people don't understand what
grooming is do you think it's important
that we do you think we need an
education about what that means exactly
yes yes i think that
one of the things i felt you know most
passionate about with this case and with
being public is that hopefully people
would hear more about what this actually
looks like this relationship building
that often is at the heart of abuse and
exploitation where there's attention and
gift-giving and
an attempt to make people feel special
and it's not just with
the you know the children or the young
adults it's also often with families um
sometimes even you know with
you know a whole community and so i
think that that's something that's not
that's not well understood and i hope
people can recognize these patterns that
predators often use i also it gives me
some concern because i have seen people
trying to co-opt the language of
grooming um and use it to you know
spread misinformation and in particular
with some of the kind of bills that have
targeted the lgbtq
communities um you know information
about about sex education is so
important information about you know um
you know sexual orientation all this
stuff actually helps people feel more
confident and and less i think
vulnerable to being targeted um and and
so i think you know understanding what
grooming is and what it's not is very
important you know and now you are a
psychologist yourself who works with
trauma survivors i would think that that
would be hard for you to do i don't know
if it brings up memories for you or
you're just
really motivated to help others
considering what you've been through
uh i think it makes my work really
meaningful to know that i can help
people going that have experienced these
kinds of things and are continuing to
heal and oftentimes i just feel so moved
by the ways that the people i work with
have
have healed and have grown so for me
it's an honor to get to do that work
well annie farmer it's really good to
have you here i hope you feel as good as
you look
because you look fantastic it's great to
be here thank you so much